[Música]
comenzamos este espacio de cinco minutos
con aníbal jozami director general de
bin al shur la bienal internacional de
arte contemporáneo de américa del sur
señor josemi gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 le pregunto cómo
se ha visto afectada la cultura durante
esta crisis por esta pandemia
coronavirus o cómo están pensando el
futuro del sector en la post pandemia le
preguntó de a más y cambió para siempre
y creo que hay cosas buenos días ante
todo y muchas gracias por consultarme
creo que hay cosas que han cambiado y
otras cosas que van a seguir igual la
virtualidad permitió que durante este
tiempo de pandemia se pudiese llegar a
muchos públicos a mucha cantidad de
gente pero evidentemente la experiencia
sensible que implica ver una obra de
arte o participar en un evento artístico
y cultural las vivencias que eso da no
van a pues no van a ser reemplazados
yo creo que es importante tener en
cuenta que esta pandemia ha traído como
consecuencias aparte del aspecto
sanitario un aumento de la
discriminación tanto de la
discriminación de género como de la
discriminación racial y en muchos países
una mayor oposición a la migración o un
desprecio al migrante esto
se da en el marco de una situación que
en la mayoría de los países desde el
punto de vista social va a ser mucho más
complicada que antes de la pandemia y
creo que esto va a llevar a que haya un
arte menos frívolo haya un arte más
comprometido haya un arte más dirigido a
las comunidades que los museos y las
instituciones se preocupen más por la
gente que los rodea y no que piensen
solamente en la taquilla es decir en las
entradas que puede implicar el turismo
en este momento muchos museos europeos
que fueron reabiertos están sufriendo
justamente por la falta de turistas esto
es lógico que los museos sean visitados
por los turistas pero esto también
implica que muchos museos se alejaron de
sus comunidades y el público físicamente
más cercano a ellos no iba creo que lo
que va a ocurrir como consecuencia de la
pandemia es
y un aumento en el nivel de compromiso
del arte un aumento en el nivel en el
nivel de contacto de los artistas y de
las instituciones culturales con sus
comunidades y al alguien un arte que
llegue mucho a la gente y donde la gente
se pueda sentir partícipe y no sea solo
exposiciones para aprovechar el turismo
cultural digamos si si les podría dar un
ejemplo cercano a ustedes de lo que yo
pienso es que lo que va a venir van a
ser expresiones artísticas mucho al
estilo de las que llevo adelante bien al
sur si hay un caso muy concreto en
colombia que es el proyecto juntos
aparte que llevamos adelante desde bien
al sur y desde instituciones culturales
de cúcuta y ese es el tipo de arte que
yo veo para el futuro señor jose amigo
se te vaya en un punto muy importante es
la presencialidad de pregunto que es tan
necesaria es consumir la cultura manera
presencial para potenciar a lo mejor de
manera entender es la cultura
yo creo que la virtualidad como le decía
antes permite llegar permite conocer
cosas pero evidentemente la vivencia
sensible de estar frente a la obra de
arte éste forma parte de forma parte de
la del experimento artístico las obras
no están terminadas hasta que no son
vistas desde una desde una obra
cinematográfica hasta una obra pictórica
se terminan con la vivencia del
espectador y con la interpretación que
el espectador hace de esa obra por eso
creo que es la presencialidad es este
indispensable digamos y que nunca va a
poder ser reemplazada por la virtualidad
que si va a colaborar para que se puedan
llegar a públicos más alejados
y distantes pero evidentemente son cosas
que tienen que ser combinables y que una
no reemplazará a otra ahora brevemente
ya para finalizar qué rol deben cumplir
los estados en todo esto que estamos
viendo postpandemia referente al arte
bueno el rol que tienen que tener los
estados es fundamental
siempre lo fue y lo va a ser más en esta
situación post pandémica hay que
reconocer que el que los estados deben
reconocer la importancia que tiene
aumentar los presupuestos aumentar los
subsidios que reciben las instituciones
culturales porque evidentemente digamos
es también esta muestra sabemos que está
perdón esta muestra esta pandemia y ha
demostrado la debilidad de las
instituciones y la debilidad de los
actores del arte si eres un tema como
uno y discutir la situación de los
artistas entonces sí sí la presencia del
estado siempre fue indispensable ahora
lo va a ser más al señor rózsa más
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en cinco minutos aquí en france
24 señor aníbal jozami director general
de bien al sur
[Música]